[Musique]
c'est un fait les français en ont marre
de la situation sanitaire actuelle et
avec elle toutes les interdictions une
colère a gagné les commerçants l'un
besoin d'actualité on a besoin de voir
des gens extra c'est le cas de florence
vandoeuvre cette propriétaire d'une
boutique de souvenirs et décoration à
dieppe et a décidé de laisser son rideau
ouvert à l'arrivée des forces de l'ordre
la femme ne s'est pas montrée très
coopérative
résultat les fonctionnaires de police
ont décidé de l'emmener au poste menotté
et de l'enfermer en garde à vue pendant
cinq heures pourtant la fin précise que
son rideau et est ouvert mais qu'elle ne
vendais rien j'ai été traitée comme une
criminelle
si elle n'a pas l'intention de porter
plainte elle compte faire parler de
cette histoire pour qu'on mette en
lumière la détresse des petits
commerçants
florence est avec nous ce soir je
voudrais remercier florence d'être avec
nous cette commerçante qui a été placé
en garde à vue
florence tout le monde a parlé que vous
êtes tellement mignonne en plus quand je
vous vois là franchement ça me fait
plaisir de vous voir est vraiment joue
sans aller très ému florence d'être là
merci bruno pas ma peau marban - amis ex
policiers du raid et président de raid
aventure organisation florence tout le
monde a parlé de vous et c'est vrai que
c'est encore un témoignage fort vous
avez été interpellé dimanche qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement
je suis arrivé à 10h d'habitude jour à
9h30 le dimanche mais là comme celle que
vit du 10 heures je vais aller refermer
photo ce que des photos parce que vous
prenez deux qui voit dans le magasin
pour les maîtres 2h prendre des photos
pour le click and collect exactement
bravo voilà tout le monde nous dit qu'il
faut faire l'avancé
voilà onze essais de voix là dessous
comme vous pouvez exactement donc la
police passe me dit vous ouvrez je sais
pas d'où je sans ouvrir parce que je
viens faire mes photos je vous dis tout
de suite tourné pour la journée je suis
nul pour jouer avec internet et tout ça
je ne sais pas en quoi donc voilà
repasse vers 11h 11h30 j'étais toujours
là et je parlais avec une clientèle
raison cru que la dame voulait acheter
donc ils m'ont dit vous ranger tous il
repasse on vous met une amende
ils sont allés voir mon confrère en face
ils lui ont dit la même chose on a fermé
surmonter déjeuner est comme ma
devanture était en travaux hier
avant-hier hier et aujourd'hui dimanche
après midi
moi je vais finir mes photos et puis je
veux comme ça je vais être bon je fais
mes photos il ya plein de gens qui m'ont
vu en train de l'est
r et où je range tout ce que j'avais
pris en photo dans le magasin j'étais
toute seule dans le magasin personnes à
la vitrine et là elles sont arrivées
c'était comme un coin de policiers trois
ou deux policiers au début trois hommes
n'ont deux hommes et une femme
d'accord ils vous disent quoi vopak vous
n'avez pas bien compris ce qu'on vous a
dit ce matin
mais pardon je range ce que voilà j'ai
fait en photo si ça je comprenais pas je
donc après c'est oui j'ai eu tort je
reconnais j'ai eu tort de les traiter de
con je vais donc fait chier vous êtes
des cons et rien d'autre à [ __ ]
voilà vous n'avez vous savez que ça
c'est pas trop jouer oui oui ça
s'appelle khamenei n'a pas ouvert depuis
des mois et des mois
robin c'est normal qu'elle a craqué le
dire oui à laraque et j'en ai
aujourd'hui pourquoi j'ai accepté mais
moi j'ai mode franchise ont tout d'abord
falloir j'ai accepté pourquoi parce que
ce matin je voulais pas quand votre
équipe m'a appelé juge non mais voilà
c'est bon et puis je prends mon café
avec plein de copines le matin comme
wind anna et nous avez raison je me dise
mais non on va jusqu'au bout j'ai dit ok
si je vais jusqu'au bout c'est pour tous
les commerçants c'est pas moi
et donc est donc vous êtes vous le redis
de voix là où vous avez tué un autre âge
qu'on appelle un outrage à agent et là
qu'est ce qui se passe
ben c'est un petit peu dégénéré parce
que
[Musique]
parce que j'étais pas d'accord je ne
comprenais pas ce qui m'arrivait et donc
là qu'est ce qui se passe là et vous
menottes alors j'ai vu des problèmes de
santé il ya deux ans j'ai excusez-moi
faut que j'aille aux toilettes
la femme me dit je vais vous accompagner
sinon voilà et puis après besson - oui
les menottes
voilà vous avez été amené au
commissariat oui comment d'ailleurs je
me suis débattue je dis la vérité je
n'avais pas du tout envie de partir
devant les gens et donc oui je me suis
débattue et j'ai crié pour que pour
alerter les gens qu'on ne savait crédit
quoi au feu aujourd'hui hélas y avait là
les pompiers sont arrivés parce qu'on
m'a toujours dit briller au secours
quand est embêté ça donne plus rien
d'accord j'ai crié au flash à parts
égales et chips incroyable et bien écrit
aux flots faut freiner comme ça on fait
au feu prévu que je sais plus ce que
j'ai dis parce que dans le feu de
l'action et je ne m'en rappelle même pas
j'ai craqué la presse avait été
traumatisée ça ne sais pas ce que
j'imagine que c'est bien c'est la
première fois que ça nous arrive
bah oui donc là vous avez été
traumatisée oui bah oui les menottes
embarquée de force on me tire la nana
tiers par les épaules l'autre agent de
police mme pous par les pieds ça fait
drôle j'arrive au poste on me la prendre
avant vous aviez l'émeute a beaucoup
même
oui les meilleurs et on est donc là vous
arriver au commissariat
ouais et on me rattache à 10 ans attaché
la highway jeu désolé je vais faire je
suis comme ça tous les jours
je sais pas si j'ai l'air d'une
délinquante me nommé attaché la neige
est attaché à la chaise prix et donc la
voulait ça ton trop longtemps au pas
longtemps à paco raymond mis en cellule
à vous avez ton cellule à bas revenus et
la totale ouais
rebelle une allure 2010 que payet sans
facebook
non mais et donc vous avez été en
cellule il était tout seul en cellule
oui d'accord et donc là là vous vous
dites quoi dans votre tête vous commencé
à paniquer non non parce que j'ai
demandé à voir un médecin
ils m'ont emmené à l'hôpital comme j'ai
eu des gros problèmes de santé il ya
quinze ans il ya deux ans et tout ça et
j'ai vu médecin de service qui m'avait
vu il ya six mois quand je suis rentré
d'urgence
vous êtes avec la police la cause est
allé voir le médecin
oui vous êtes accompagné par la police
vous êtes entendu pas d'accord il est
entendue après par le pdj oui mais quand
je suis revenue et trois corps donc j'ai
craqué à l'hôpital je me suis mise à
pleurer comme une manne entend faire
excusez moi mais j'en ai évoqué et vous
disais quoi les policiers apprennent sur
le chemin de sa vie voyait pas les
achats rien dit sur le chemin ils ont
même mis les gyrophares donc chiyo and
roll et comment ça s'est terminé cette
affaire comment ça s'est terminé bien
j'ai eu une une avocate qui est arrivé
je vais raconter d'accord après on est
monté dans le bureau d'un policier
j'ai pas trop compris votre déposition
qui après ma déposition qui m'a lui
aussi la déposition des policiers bien
sûr et là j'étais pas d'accord avec tous
les termes est ce que ces maisons des
vous les aviez traité de con ça c'est
vrai d'accord ils ont dû craquer ou à
des cons voilà ça je sais probablement
certains alors si vous êtes donc on veut
[Rires]
vraiment là c'est vrai j'aurais
peut-être pas dû ouais c'est clair
la colère est partie de la colère est
partie des voilages et pétales a jamais
eu dans mon âme et je passe au tribunal
avril
ainsi qu'à l'escale à cochons pas bruno
pomart ben oui oui et d'abord traduit
vous pouvez avoir même les indemnités à
payer aux fonctionnaires de police
rappel à la loi
stage de citoyenneté éventuellement voir
une fermeture administrative ça c'est
d'être évident qui le décidera moi moi
ce que ce que ce que je vous reproche je
vais pas vous chargez évidemment c'est
pas 2 c'est pas le but c'est pas non
plus la l'a fait du monde est-ce que
vous avez ce qu'on vous a fait mais je
pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
essentiel dans votre dans votre histoire
c'est que les fonctionnaires survenu
reprise c'est à dire vous avez un
commerce qui est non essentiels donc il
était censé être fermée même si vous
faisiez les photos ils sont venus une
fois ils ont faits d'apologie du
discernement ils ont eu et de la
pédagogie
bon ça s'est bien passé le deuxième
forum ils reviennent il se dit pourquoi
c'est encore ouvert et la troisième fois
qu'ils y viennent se dit elle se fout de
notre gueule un bon je pense que dans
leur tête et quand vous avez évidemment
quand au moment où ils vous ont
interpellé évidemment c'est partir en
cacahuète
ça c'est le truc classique vous les avez
outragés évidemment un rebellyon c'est
le procès ce jour moi je voulais pas le
jeter l'opprobre sur mes collègues
policiers parce que ils sont dans une
situation actuelle tout le monde le sait
avec ce qu'on vide qui est compliquée et
je comprends que votre situation en tant
que commerçante est très compliqué mais
en même temps si vous aviez su vous
contenir un petit peu madame je sais que
c'est pas simple j'entends je pense que
ça ne se serait pas passé comme ça bon
alors c'est très sincèrement ce que je
pense
est ce que vous êtes choqué par la
réaction des policiers ce qu'ils disent
oui géraldine oui en fait cela montre
que vous êtes en détresse et c'est
normal et que les policiers sont en
détresse et c'est normal parce que ça
fait un an qu'ils contrôlent si les
masses qui sont bien placés si on est en
distanciation après moi je trouve qu il
ya la loi et puis à l'esprit de la loi
m madame a quand même expliqué qu'elle
était en train de faire des photos
qu'elle galéré pour ce week end
collègues c'était compliqué pour elle
c'est un oui mais elle explique à chaque
fois oui mais de prendre des photos de
tous ces artisans et si tous les
magasins pour pareil tout et tout et les
autochtones et pas choquer il ya deux
choses en fait qu'on place en garde à
vue une commerçante parce qu'elle a
ouvert son commerce tout ça scandaleux
surtout qu'aujourd'hui un vrai flou on
sait plus qui est ouvert ce qu'ils
fermeraient les injustices au sein des
commerçants ça c'est une forme et elle
elle devait être fermé le lan maintenant
mais voilà je trouve que c'est de même
trop sévère pour ça le truc en revanche
si vraiment il ya eu outrage aux
policiers non ça ne me choque pas tiré
le tout à l'heure vous parlez des états
unis aux états unis vous traitez un flic
de couleur vous savez une sanction
énorme vous faites des monts céphalées
c'est vrai c'est pas des modèles mais
manon même en france c'est vrai que l'on
a on a tendance à être un peu dur et les
policiers donc c'est vraiment eu des
insultes je trouve que c'est normal
voyez sans merci d'avancé je voudrais
jouer juste ceux qui sont pas choqués et
gilles verdez et oui parce que la brasse
oki wes kizomba choqué oui alors
vous racontez très calmement adam votre
histoire mais je me suis documenté sur
la sphère effectivement il ya eu
rébellion outrage
ils sont passés trois fois donc un
moment les volets de l'union sérieux
rébellion ou comme on le ferait belle
rebelle n'a jamais jamais il ya lyon
bien des règles d'accord il ya la loi et
dont ils viennent
la loi avait calé pas dangereuse cet
homme effectivement mais la loi c'est la
garde à vue et d'ailleurs vous n'aurez
qu'un rappel à la loi c'est à dire vous
ne serez pas condamner ni sanctionnés
plus durement
je trouve que c'est proportionnel s'est
passé donc je ne suis pas choqué oloron
florence vous regrettez vous avez vous
d'avoir travaillé essayer de travail
s'est passé à la peau j'ai fait mes
photos fait ces photos
madame vous avez essayé de leur parler
comme ça aux policiers comme vous nous
parler à moi soit j'ai parlé aux
policiers qui m'a interrogé après oui
mais avant au début tu vois ça s'est
bien passé mais c'est la troisième
fonction
la première fois oui la deuxième vous
ranger tous mes jeux c'est normal ils
nous ont avertis le fois une deuxième
fois et la troisième fois j'étais en
train de vendre j'étais toujours en
train de faire ses fameuses est jamais
qu à sa vie de tous les habitants c'est
le détail on dit toujours que le diable
est dans les détails
est ce que vraiment c'est l'émeute moins
de chalets sont donc en commissariat
rattaché
il ya beaucoup de gens ya beaucoup de
gens que ça choque voilà écoute les
connerie canada ses dires il un tel nom
oui mais regardez là prêts dont elle a
fait trois ans d'acquis doute on est
tourné souvent du côté de la police mais
là objectivement tête y avait un peu de
discernement avoir franchement la dame à
la pas l'air excuse mais je veux sans
vous offenser bon allez c'est quand même
pas un muscle or il ya trois policiers
discernement n'est jamais j'y crois pas
du tout très sincèrement c'est qu'il ya
eu vraiment vrai pour vous mettez des
modes
une dame parce que là non pas une op à
brocarder l'ont pas ils ont pas savait
où il a été menotté mais c'est pour
amener son lot de joies des jeux pas
l'accord d'hier à qui on met les
menottes alors nicolas choisir à qui on
met les menottes nous étions nous
aurions bien sûr le met pas la dame
aussi on va dire pourquoi on l'a mais on
les réalise alors nicolas
non mais je comprends pas ce que tu dit
benjamin se dire qu'on va choisir
maintenant par rapport par rapport au
visage ou par rapport au passé ses
actions maintenant pour les malins qui
contient un danger bien sûr dois je me
sens désolé le commerce devaient être
fermés joue aujourd'hui mois des restos
clandestins qui sont fermés après une
visite il ya même pas trois visites
madame je suis vraiment désolé pour vous
mais ils sont venus vous voir trois fois
et non pas que ça à faire les policiers
surtout en ce moment
donc ils ont pris des décisions après
sur les menottes je ne peux pas bien il
ya des gens qui disent hey ya des gens
qui disent si les policiers n'avaient
pas mis les menottes al alam on aurait
dit pourquoi ils n'émettent pas la
vérité mais ça oui mais c'est là c'est
la même règle tout mis tout ce que
disent les gens d'ici la procédure après
c'est vrai que voilà florence sa peau
mais elle a vécu ça mais c'est la
procédure et ses valises pareils propos
pour tout le monde
faire des photos pendant une journée
dans sa besace et attendez moi je suis
pas policier j'étais pas sur les lieux
dont je vais pas évidemment bien
évidemment non mais c'est un bilan belle
film en fait on demande aux commerçants
et même aux gens de se réinventer pour
pouvoir survivre pendant tout la grosse
10 la grande distribution elle
s'enrichit les petits commerçants meurt
donc madame elle a choisi dimanche pour
faire ces photos pourquoi parce que
comme vous l'avez dit si j'ai bien
compris
lundi mardi et aujourd'hui mercredi il y
avait de la peinture on sait très bien
qu'il ya de la peinture fraîche sur la
façade on peut pas les sortir ses
foulards ses trucs et tout pour faire
des photos
donc parfois les policiers aurait juste
dû se dire ok elle reste un peu plus
tardivement parce que lundi mardi
mercredi elle pourra pas le faire
paula c'est une gentille dame madame est
adorable la gentille le 2 mai mais vous
n'étiez pas comme ça ce jour là vous
aviez très agité et les menottes au sida
c'est l'excès mais oui mais oui mais il
faut le meilleur le bayer
moui mais elle travaillait mais oui
d'accord là dessus
vos papiers et vous les faites bien
comment ça et dont l on est là j'ai
répondu j'en ai pas je suis sdf bouquin
subi les dégâts les bacs mais pas
qu'avec des mots et non mais oui mais
oui mais oui ses passions mais non mais
pas le patient ne va pas jusque là mais
c'est de la provocation c'est un outrage
fait aux comportements qu'on doit pas
voir mais c'est pas de la puebla ses
champions même si elle reste fermée
non mais là c'est la provocation est la
sienne lorsqu'elle dit c'est de la
provocation oui guillaume benjamin
dating vous êtes en train de disculper
madame en raison de son apparence ou
d'italie
c'est au tour à ford ont juste laissé on
va les menottes à quelqu'un comme ça ça
veut dire quoi si c'est un jeune d'à
d'une mine de ces prêts non mais tu as
raison il a l'air simple la raison d'un
jeune qui traite les policiers de cons
avec une certaine apparence d'un certain
seuil d'accord écrire une accusée de
suite et madame parce qu elle n
mais c'est vrai que vous avez l'air très
sympathique et vous l'êtes ressentez
vous la clé vous là deux poids deux
mesures servent et ses jeux délit de
faciès que tu dis c dans l'air et la
voir guillaume nicolas
après je suis désolé mais mettez-vous
aussi l'autre côté alors vous avez
effectivement très sympathique mais oui
ça c'est ce que les policiers n'ont que
ça à faire excusez moi même et donc
d'aller voir tous les commerçants toute
la journée une fois deux fois trois fois
quatre cinq ans allez il faut fermer la
porte et vous et machins et puis notez
aussi il faut noter que oui madame
finissait photo ah et puis monsieur là
ils ouvrent parce qu'il fait son
inventaire mai mais ils n'ouvrent pas
pour le grand bébé attendait commencent
à abandonner voilà il faut respecter les
lois chiale question pour bruno pomart
d'après le code pénal des menottes
doivent être utilisés uniquement si la
personne est jugée dangereuse pour
autrui rc ou pour elle même en quoi
l'autre à signifie danger mais c'est
laissé à l'appréciation des policiers
tout simplement s'ils ont donc ils sont
appréciées qu'elles étaient
dangereusement mais s'il était virulente
à ce moment là c'est une façon de
pouvoir la mener au commissariat de
façon pour éviter de toucher sur helpe
assez énorme et c'est heureusement il ya
des dramatiques en même temps qu'elle et
neuropathique mois sa situation me fait
beaucoup trop rires je suis désolé ça me
fait rire parce que il ya un moment
donné où moi je pense qu'il faut avoir
aussi un peu de bon sens et je trouve
que cette dame n'a pas fait une chose
assez grave pour être menotté on peut
aussi penser à l'humiliation
enfin cette dame à la pala pas
l'habitude de la violence donc on lui
met les menottes devant tout le monde
les gens dans sa rue devant ses voisins
on l'emmène dans une voiture avec des
gyrophares je trouve que c'est je trouve
que c'est beaucoup d'autres situations
évoquées ce g20 mais la dit prête à la
place des policiers
laurence est ce que vous vous êtes vous
est marqué par cette histoire
ah bah oui quand même tu peux c'est la
première fois de ma vie que ça m'arrive
vous avez eu peur ah oui oui oui quand
ils sont venus oui j'ai eu peur je leur
demandais ce qui se passait je
comprenais pas c'est pour ça que j'ai
pété les plombs
oui a voulu devenir busage année vous
allez refaire des outrages vous allez
faire un tour à faire discrète mais très
bien merci en tout cas florence d'avoir
fait ça a été un plaisir et c'est vrai
que c'est important si vous avez vous
été la personne du jour à avoir tout le
monde vous voulez sur le plateau de la
sq là aujourd'hui c'est ton versant tout
avec pour tous les autres commerçants
qui égalaient un petit ou gros plus gros
il faut ouvrir les commerces moi je suis
d'accord avec florent mais franchement
comme je le dis à chaque fois dans des
petits commerces comme celui de florence
vous croyez vraiment qu'ils à 20
personnes qui viennent dans le temps
elle serait très très content qu'ils
doivent clients à chaque fois en même
temps si on a quatre c'est le bon centre
mais deux voilà donc les chéris je vous
dis franchement ça fait plusieurs fois
que je lance un appel
il faut ouvrir les petits commerçants
comme ça qu'ils ont des boutiques les
choses voilà qui sont en train de crever
et je comprends aussi que l qu'elles en
aient marre là la pauvre florence voilà
et je vous le dis aujourd'hui c'est pas
on n'aura pas 25 personnes dans le
magasin florence
sinon elle serait elle dirait voilà tout
le monde ouvrirait des petits magasins
comme souvent cela
donc si elle a deux clientes avec elle
au moins ça leur permet de papoter un
peu las de vivre à peu et de continuer
un peu à exercer leur métier dans les
lois ils veulent pas que les grandes
surfaces soient ouvertes les grandes
surfaces de la relation beaucoup de
monde mais ils ont pas fait la
distinction entre les grandes surfaces
de vêtements je vais voter non
lorsqu'on 500 m² sur la planche